Speaker 1: Let's go next to Mohammed from
I can't actually see where somewhere that
starts with the letter T.. Where
are you calling from Muhammad?
Speaker 5: I'm from Troy, Michigan.
Speaker 1: Try Michigan. Troy, Troy
Troy, Michigan. Oh, okay. All
right. Mohammed from Troy. Go ahead.
Speaker 5: All right. Hello. But
basically, I wanted to discuss with you
my thoughts on midterms, especially since. This
is probably a global flashpoint for thinking, but
yeah, I feel like based on things that are
happening in recent days, especially with.
The far right wing just refusing to take the
vaccine and basically making a miracle carers and
disproportionately dying. Yes, I hate
that I have to sort of bring a political.
What's the word I'm looking for?
Mm hmm. I don't know, but basically, I
think this whole hurt in the midterms.
Speaker 1: And let me see if I can
understand what you're saying, Mohammed.
Are you saying that at this point, the deaths
are skewing towards the Republicans so much
that they might literally kill enough voters
to lose some races? Is that the idea? Yeah,
essentially, yeah. Yeah. I mean, listen,
Speaker 2: theoretically, yeah, but
Speaker 5: basically they're saying that like our
midterms, like 2022 is going to be a red wavier
based on how things are going right
now. They are losing that red wave year.
I don't know about that, Mohammed.
Speaker 1: I'm not so sure about
that. And here's the thing about it the
turnout is typically so low in midterms.
And although there is absolutely a Partizan gap in
who's dying from COVID, you need that Partizan gap
to overwhelm the fact that the party
that loses the White House in one year
tends to vote at a much higher rate in that
first midterm. So I you're completely right
in a general sense. I don't know that that's
actually the way it's going to go. I think we
need to assume there will be a red wave
and make sure we're fighting against it
at every opportunity. I would be really careful.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I don't. Well, what I was trying
to say, I wasn't I was thinking like, Yeah,
there will probably be like a right away and
this sense of like our Republicans will, like,
maybe take back the House and possibly take back
the Senate. But if things go well for them, but
like based on how things are going right now,
because like people like everyone and like
media and otherwise were saying, like 2020
was supposed to be a blue wave year, and it was
an utter disaster for Democrats in 2020 because
they lost about over a dozen seats in the House.
Right? They. Barely won the Senate because of
the Big Lie and people like Lin Wood and
Sidney Powell literally saying, Don't vote.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, that's a good point. I think
the take away Muhammad is we've got to not assume
the outcome and we must all go out and vote
in every race that we have available to us.
Muhammad from Troy, Michigan. I appreciate the
call. We are going to go to a very short break.
If you're holding. Don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones in a moment.